the voice returned for season 19 last
night with all the coaches and
contestants socially distancing
but the distance didn't stop them from
taking jabs at each other
yeah in this political season john
legend took the opportunity to run an ad
calling out blake shelton's lies
jim you don't want to work with blake
come on
don't listen to it can't always trust
this guy as a son of a pastor you want
someone
you can really trust and believe their
word
and we got an important message i need
to uh
present to jim blake shelton
is alive could you block me
all he does is lie that's one of my
favorites with lady gaga
isn't the time to pick a coach you can
believe him
ladies and gentlemen a coach with
integrity
you're gonna do so great congratulations
so this season pick a coach we can all
trust
[Music]
i'm john legend and i approve this
message
i may be full of crap but i won't be
deterred
okay
i do lie but it's only when something is
important to me
now what the hell kind of things does
that mean
it's worth it to me to lie to lie
to these other coaches to get somebody
like you on my team
someone says i love john having a funny
bone in them yeah it's like an election
ad
i mean this is the part we've talked
about this before this is the part of
the voice that i love
i mean one is great to see them back
again because yeah it's been off they're
delayed with this season
but yeah this is the part of the voice i
love it's just the four of them really
bantering
and we've talked about this multiple
times i think why
this is why you don't really see stars
come out of the show is because
what really makes this show work is this
part where it's the four of them the
four coaches
kind of bantering with each other all
through the blind auditions and it's
really not
about the contestants they're like just
like you know the plot point to get them
going at each other
so that's like that's what makes the
show so entertaining like i find like as
soon as the blind auditions are over
and they get to like the battle rounds i
kind of tune out every season like this
is the stuff i love to see the four
coaches kind of have fun with each other
yeah their chemistry is great i love
just seeing gwen and blake
like just their little moments i'm
always thinking like oh i wonder what
that conversation in the car is like
after that or
you know and john legend is adorable
kelly clarkson's beloved i mean
they're really it's a really good
selection of judges like it's a
feel-good show we need this yeah
yeah mar just has a bunch of like crying
laughing emojis
quick says blake shelton is a liar all
he does after is he says that himself uh
as well yeah it's gonna be interesting
to see like how this show evolves
because i do
think after this season i think they
need to
change up the coaches because like
gwen's come back i think this is her
third time being a coach like john's
been there for
four seasons now i think kelly
i don't like i don't know like but i
think kelly's a staple on the show now i
don't think they're gonna get
rid of kelly especially because she's
you know her talk shows nbc as well so i
think she's staying
blake won't go anywhere probably but no
i do think they need a new
like they need to bring in some fresh
bread like at least keys was great fresh
blood
nick jonas's great flesh blood last
season so yeah somebody else
um who else could come in um well who
can go
that's the i'm like staring at you like
hold on now who's gonna go well gwen
only gwen only tends to do yeah
so they'll probably yeah we could have
gwen go we're trying like maybe like uh
kesha or
i'm trying to think of some people pink
um
pink justin timberlake
just throwing out names here
i'm saying all kinds of indifference
i just i'm like hold on what are we i'm
like but i'm like kesha like
she does have a flare yeah
i got it i got it personality yeah like
i'd have to like
but you know what's weird is like you
can hear the name of someone and assume
that like what are they going to say or
like what would their you know what are
they like you don't maybe not familiar
with them
and then they surprise you
right like they go on their
personalities are amazing
code says miguel ma says i would like to
see
kylie minogue i think kylie minogue's on
like i know she's australian i know
she's on the uh
australian one of the uk one i think
she's been on as a coach on one of the
voices
um around the world yeah like i think
it's just good to mix it up like i think
you can't just keep the same four
coaches all
the time and yeah like when's the back a
few times john's been there several
seasons i think it's time to
mix it up okay i'm not i'm not gonna lie
i miss mariah carey when she was a judge
oh that's true yeah just the darling i
don't know
and her personality is actually
hilarious i don't think people know how
hilarious she really is
right i think they all just think of her
a certain way i think she'd actually do
good on a show like that
yeah uh charisses are in a grande um not
that they would be on together but
when he said mariah i thought of nicki
minaj but no they couldn't be on
together but
no one wanted one of the other you're
going to cardi b would be hilarious
she'd be like yeah would be good too
but no i do think you need to keep it
fresh yeah they need to keep it fresh on
the show so i think it's time to yeah
mixed up you've had these four
judges you know being doing several
seasons so it's time to mix it up so but
no it's still super entertaining i love
watching it it's that
it's that comfort food we need right now
kisha it's not comfort food